those stories and their more with us now
is retired General Colin Powell who
served at President Bush's chairman of
the Joint Chiefs of Staff during the
first Gulf War he was also President
Reagan's national security advisor and
Secretary of State under President
George W Bush general so good to have
you here this morning that story -
really what about the president's
personal diplomacy it helped him in this
country immensely but the story you just
told us a familiar one because I knew
the interpreter I can tell you he was
terrified he was always terrified no
problem and Gorbachev was also an
interesting person to see with President
Bush and with President Reagan and I was
also national security adviser to the
bush and to Reagan of course in the last
few years the administration and it was
a fascinating period as the changeover
was taking place between President
Reagan and now President Bush okay what
was happening there with the Soviet
Soviet Union was it was disintegrating
and talked a little bit about President
Bush's restraint in dealing with that
because Democrats were saying go take a
victory lap no he wouldn't do it he
would never do any such thing because
his mother would come down on him but
that was the way he was almost in on
everything after the Gulf War American
people were absolutely overjoyed with
what they saw their soldiers sailors
airmen and Marines doing and New York
wanted to have this massive ticker tape
parade which they put together going up
Broadway just like the old days
and Bush said I'm not gonna go mr.
president why not this belongs to the
Troops not to me mm so he was and how
did that humility define his presidency
it was always there
he was tough but no one think that he
was soft and humility but he'd always
cared for the other person he always
tried to look out for the needs and the
loss of the other person and so when
when the Cold War ended and the Soviet
Union was falling apart he was more
interested in what they needed to become
a functioning society in a democratic
system than anything else it's another
example of tomorrow there will be a
group of soldiers sailors airmen and
Marines
who are coming here who were veterans of
the invasion of Panama and Desert Storm
he specifically asked that we assemble
this group of troops so that they could
pay tribute to him but that is what he
really wanted he wanted to pay tribute
to them the general I think about - I
mean he was the last President to have
served in combat you shot down during
World War two lost his two crewmates
mm-hmm he knows loss he knows he knows
loss and when we ended the Gulf War is
rather surprisingly to the public he did
that because he said is there any reason
to kill more Americans or to kill more
Iraqis and he wanted to bring the war to
an end the war was defined in time and
space we're gonna kick the Iraqis out of
Kuwait we are going to restore the
government of Kuwait make sure that Iraq
doesn't have the capability to do that
again
all that was accomplished and this
nonsensical comment about well why
didn't he go to Baghdad and that's nice
to say that now but he and the United
Nations and the world had a mission and
that was to deal with the Iraqis in
Kuwait and not to go take over the
country of Iraq anyway hope do you hope
that side of the same would fall didn't
happen but he once told Gorbachev that
he was cautious but not timid and I
think it's exactly right people talked
about his lack of the vision thing but
on foreign policy he did have a vision
right this is nonsense this was a man
with vision he just didn't you know
broadcast it but he knew what he was
doing he was with Reagan for those years
when the Soviet Union was starting to
come apart when Gorbachev came on the
scene and he followed that very very
closely and so he was ready to take over
from Reagan and he knew what he was
dealing with in Gorbachev but he was
cautious he was cautious and in the
first few months of his administration
he was a little reluctant to move out
too quickly to work with the Russians
but then when he realized what he had
and what they were needing he jumped
right in and he immediately went you
recall that that summit meeting they had
on a ship in a storm
that's just the way that's the way he
was he was cautious and whenever we had
to meet on something whether it was
Panama or Desert Storm and Desert Shield
you would sit with him in the Oval
Office the gang of eight we called
ourselves and we all knew each other
from other positions so we were we were
buddies but we knew had a fight and
argue with each other and we would do
that in front of the president and he
was just listening or chewing his lip
and asking a few questions but he was
very very cautious and he would take it
all in and he would not make some jump
decision out of nowhere he would think
it through and then decide what was best
for the country but not only what was
best for the country was best for the
world he said he saw the world not just
the country America first America has
always been first in my heart but to
make America first you have to be part
of a broader world and that's what he
understood well general thank you so
much for talking about his legacy and I
think the values that many people are
mourning as well thank you so much and
we will cover a series of events over
the next four days as the country says
goodbye to President Bush former
president will be taken from Houston to
Washington later this morning and CBS
News will bring you that ceremony in a
special report we'll have other special
reports this afternoon after mr. Bush
arrives at Joint Base Andrews he will
lie in state in the Capitol Rotunda
until Wednesday morning and there will
be a funeral service at the National
Cathedral in Washington on Wednesday
before mr. Bush's casket is returned
home to Texas after a private funeral
who will be buried on Thursday next to
his wife and his daughter Robin at his
Presidential Library at Texas A&M
University